avec sa fille avec colleen vous avez des
relations de quel ordre non malades très
bien meilleur que finalement votre psy
avec richard berry oui mais j'habitais
avec mais je la voyais pas beaucoup je
vais question doit beaucoup pas vos
coûts de tous belle feinte fois dans ma
vie ah oui c'est tout ça a duré un an et
demi c'était très court c'était pas
beaucoup alors aujourd'hui on s'est
reconstruit mais les connais les
collines aujourd'hui pour vous c'est
quoi ça est-ce que c'est quelqu'un qui
fait un kick il vous pousse et c'est ça
qui a menti c'est quelqu'un qu'on va
sceller juste qu'il a dit c'est pas moi
et j'ai aujourd'hui je suis là oui je
suis allé voir le juge le juge nous a
donné raison et donc je suis très
heureuse aujourd'hui je respire un peu
même s'il y a une appel c'est pas un peu
ça ne la vérité on le sait toujours est
en marche et lendemain elle à nous pour
joindre à eux ont chanté et puis on est
venu pour vous parler de ça va pour été
victime aujourd'hui on est plus vite
nous revient me reconstruire ma vie où
vous vivez aujourd'hui pardon oui
j'essaie de revivre jeu c'est très
difficile d oublier ça parce que c'est
ce qu'on tourne et on essaie de nous
détruire et nous salir mon nom avait
après tout ce que j'ai pu faire un don
en france bon ok j'y suis pas parfait tu
peux avoir des défauts mais mais pas des
défauts comme ça pour horrible si
lorient b vous avez votre donner votre
sentiment sur ce qu'elle dit sur vous et
richard berry est ce que vous avez un
sentiment aussi sur ce qui est dit sur
sa relation avec son père ou est ce que
vous croyez trop neutres comme j'ai pas
été là dès que je connais pas ce que
s'est passé pendant 40 ans je ne les ai
pas vus donc elle non plus donc c'est
quand même un peu tu vois farfelues pour
moi donc voilà benjamin est ce que la
relation qu'il avait avec son père déjà
été été tendu parce que ça ressemble
alors qu'on sait pas mais on apprend
qu'elle veut se venger de quelque chose
alors oui oui ceux d'entre vous voilà
contre son père oui pm si bien sûr mais
après pas par la suite on a pris on a
appris son existence en chemin c'est pas
c'est pas un chemin facile
elle est sûrement ait eu des problèmes
dans sa vie comme il était jeune avec sa
mère je sais pas c'est ce qu'elle
maintienne pas ça nous appartient pas on
ait jamais fait quoi que ce soit on a
l'impression que vous dites qu'est ce
qu'on vient fermer pas vraiment ils
disent qui secoue vient faire là voilà
ça c'est ça et oui on n'a rien à voir là
dedans et on est sans cesse à chaque
fois on à voir là dedans non seulement
on était quatre dans cette caisse à la
hausse grâce à des photos que vous voyez
derrière ça va être jugé honteux ce que
je veux dire c'est que s'il m'avait pas
mis dans l me parle elle ne parle que de
moi dans ces scènes je suis avec elle
elle elle me l'a dit tu étais avec moi
tu as fait si tu as fait ça moi ce n'est
pas ça m'a prêté 2 [ __ ] on peut dire aussi
si vous êtes dans un déni du coup une
amnésie alors seulement chasse ps si je
peux comprendre de nommer ligue s'est
pas remis moi j'aimais pas du tout
richard je me rappelle de tout ce que
j'aimais pas de lui de tout mais
traumatise que j'ai eue avec lui qui
n'ont rien à voir avec un truc pervers
de la piscine j'ai pas réussi à mettre
la tête sous l'eau pendant 35 ans kim il
m'apprenait à nager en me jetant maxime
comme ce qu'on faisait il ya 40 ans sauf
que moi je vais très mal vécu et pendant
35 ans j'ai pas mis ma tête ce moment on
fait pareil ban avait des requins